hello everyone
welcome to another episode of science
and technology q a
for kids and others so we have a bunch
of
questions that i see saved up here let
me try and um
take a look at these let's see it was a
question here from
b2 asking uh
what is beta decay okay let me see what
i can
do about that one so
most of the time when we have atoms they
the all standard
matter is made of atoms there are the
atoms the different types of atoms are
the
different entries in the periodic table
you know hydrogen helium lithium
beryllium boron and so on
each of those different entries in the
periodic table represents
uh a an atom with a different number of
protons in its nucleus
so hydrogen has one proton helium has
two protons and so on
the nucleus of an atom has both uh can
have
a bunch of protons in it and also has a
bunch of neutrons in it
protons are positively charged they have
electric charge
neutrons have no electric charge so
most standard uh kinds of atoms
um are
have um just my computer
is going crazy and overheating itself i
wonder why
uh the um
[Music]
okay in any case um
so the the most most standard kinds of
atoms
you once you make that kind of atom
you're
you're stuck with it so to speak you
make some hydrogen
to make some tungsten you make some gold
it's just going to stick around
forever in that form nothing nothing
will happen to it
um but some kinds of atoms some chemical
elements
are unstable and uh they the nuclei will
just self-destruct after some amount of
time
and so for example uh if you go beyond
uranium which is element number 92 has
92 protons in its nucleus if you go
beyond uranium to
elements like plutonium actinium uh
all these kinds of things um you will
uh the those those atoms
have nuclei that are not stable and will
spontaneously self-destruct
and when they self-destruct they produce
uh
that's the they're said to be
radioactive and the reason they're said
to be radioactive is because when they
self-destruct
the pieces that come out are radiation
they're going at uh
you know they're usually going at high
speed and they're sort of the fragments
of that nucleus
that break apart and uh uh and produce
radiation and that radiation uh can be
quite harmful because
uh you know the little fragment of um
some
some nucleus that breaks apart uh is
going at very high speed and it's
just a little particle but it'll it'll
if it uh
hits a piece of dna in one of your cells
it can disrupt that dna
and that can eventually lead the dna to
to make that cell become cancerous or
whatever else so it's it's
it's kind of bad to get radiation from
self-destructing
atoms um to to go through you
uh so the um uh
so in any case the the the main um uh
so that that's sort of the idea of
radioactivity is
when there's sort of self-destructing
nuclei in in atoms
and that's the only way that that an
atom of something like gold or hydrogen
or whatever else
ever changes into anything else is by
its nucleus sort of self-destructing or
maybe something kicking its nucleus so
hard
that it that it uh changes or
self-destructs
okay so when nuclei self-destruct this
was something discovered
the radioactivity was discovered around
120 years ago now
um and when it was first discovered
um people identified three different
kinds of radioactivity
uh alpha decay beta decay and gamma
decay
um it turns out there are actually some
additional kinds of
radioactivity a very common one is
called spontaneous fission spontaneous
fission what happens is
it's a big globulous nucleus and the
thing just isn't
quite doesn't hold itself together quite
strongly enough and eventually
it just falls apart and that's what
happens for example
to uranium-235 which is famous because
it's what's used in lots of nuclear
reactors and things like that
um and it uh it falls apart very slowly
it takes a billion years to on average
to fall apart
but it falls apart by spontaneous
fission it just sort of isn't too big a
nucleus and it can't quite
keep itself together the strong nuclear
forces can't quite keep it together
and just falls apart okay so there are
other kinds of so these kinds of
radioactivity alpha
alpha decay beta decay gamma decay um
they're all different kinds of
radioactivity and they're all really
quite different
um when they were first discovered
people just said oh the nucleus fell
apart
and it produced radiation um and they
were just sort of
they didn't really know that they were
so different but so what are those
different kinds of radioactivity
alpha decay is the nucleus
basically falls apart by emitting a
piece that is two protons and two
neutrons it's like the
nucleus of helium iv and that that whole
lump comes out of the nucleus
that's one kind of of decay actually
there's another kind that
is not part of the standard
classification which is the nucleus just
loses a neutron um but uh but so alpha
decays is one type
uh beta decay which was the the thing
that was being asked about
um here's what beta decay is beta decay
uh let's see how best to explain it um
basically what happens is
um a neutron is transformed into a
proton
an electron and an anti-neutrino
so protons so far as we know if you just
take a proton
which is the nucleus of the standard
kind of hydrogen it's just a single
proton
so far as we know protons are completely
stable they were created
uh you know a proton that was created at
the beginning of the universe
unless something hit it very hard it's
still around today
and it hasn't decayed and
self-destructed in any way
and about um in around 1980 or so
people had reasons to think based on
theories about particle physics
that the proton was likely to somehow be
unstable
and so big efforts were made to try and
find out if protons were unstable how do
you find out if protons were unstable
basically you get a great big tank of
stuff
and you try and see whether any of that
stuff
spontaneously self-destructs even though
it was made of atoms
that were not did not have radioactivity
it's a tricky thing to figure out
because like how do you make sure
there's absolutely no atom that has any
radioactivity there
how do you make sure that there's
nothing coming from the outside like a
cosmic ray
of a like a high energy proton coming
from the sun or something
that uh kind of goes through your your
big
big tank of stuff and so people
typically put these big tanks of stuff
in deep mines a couple of a couple of
miles underground
so there's a couple of miles of rock
sort of shielding it from anything
coming from
in from uh like from cosmic rays or
something
and um sometimes a popular place was
things like road tunnels
and under for example mont blanc in the
alps
there's a road tunnel which is sort of
drilled underneath the
um uh underneath the rock of montblanc
and um i guess there's a side room from
the tunnel which
um uh is full of physics experiments now
um but uh the the and then the next
issue is
can you make sure that there's no kind
of natural radioactivity in your tank of
stuff
because you know in the earth for
example it's pretty common to find um
radon for example it's a thing people
worry about
in in houses and things like that from
different kinds of uh
building practices and so on um but
radon is a
is a as a radioactive um
uh there's a radioactive
nucleus that um uh is quite commonly
found
and has a long enough uh lifetime
that uh it it sticks around for many
years i don't remember what the lifetime
of radon is maybe
uh decades or centuries something like
that
um uh so it can it can stick around for
that period of time
but so you have to make sure you don't
have those kinds of things you've got a
lump of
of you've got a big uh vat of of stuff
that is as far as you you know just
contains completely stable nuclei
and potentially like uh hydrogen like
hydrogen nuclei and water and things
like this and
so far as you know it's just going to
stay there for the rest of eternity
and so what you look for is that that
proton
that said okay time's up i'm going to
self-destruct
and what does a proton self-destruct
into if a proton is going to
self-destruct
it kind of has to be something that has
a positive electric charge
and um the the only thing lighter than a
proton that has a positive electric
charge is an anti-electron
or a positron and so the the decay of a
proton would have to be in
something like a positron maybe
neutrinos which have almost zero mass
and maybe photons
which have zero mass and so if a
proton was going to decay it would have
to decay in something like a positron
neutrino
photon things like this and when that
happens
that positron because of the the the the
mass of the proton has to be converted
into energy
of um that means that that positron ends
up being a rapidly moving positron
and you can observe a sort of a rapidly
moving positron because
of the the signature it makes in in
something like water
uh well it particularly makes a thing
called cherenkov radiation
um because basically it's moving
well it it let me let me not
particularly explain how that works
um but it makes essentially a a flash of
blue light
um as a result of being this thing
that's moving really quickly
um through a medium like water
so okay so as far as we know protons are
stable
neutrons on the other hand are not
stable and if you were able to just get
a free neutron you would able to pluck a
neutron out from a nucleus
the neutron will decay and its lifetime
is around 15 minutes
um and what does it decay into a neutron
decays into a proton
an electron and an antineutrino and
so a free neutron undergoes
beta decay a free neutron undergoes this
kind of decay
where you get out electrons and
anti-neutrinos
um and so what's happening in beta decay
is that the
neutrons that are in nucleus usually the
nucleus is kind of holding the neutrons
and keeping that
the essentially the the energy um
that's binding the nucleus together is
making the neutron
not be able to undergo that kind of
decay
but somehow the neutron in a nucleus
which is unstable to beta decay
the neutron is kind of loose enough that
it's able to do what it would do if it
was a free neutron
and decay into a proton and an electron
imagine neutrino
the reason that the neutron is not
decaying in an ordinary nucleus
which doesn't have beta decay
um essentially it's this it's the the
there's
a nucleus is held together by binding by
being
bound together by all these protons and
neutrons are stuck together by this
thing called the strong nuclear force
which you can see in a variety of kinds
of ways but it's usually thought of as
being due to the exchange of these
particles called pions
it's a short-range force it only it's uh
unlike if you if you were to say how
much
it kind of makes all these all these
particles stick together
but if you say well it makes something
further away stick together the answer
is no
it has a range that is only about the
size of a nucleus so
uh unless it's kind of just this very
local thing
now in some cases uh like in a neutron
star a neutron star is a giant
collection of neutrons
about 10 kilometers across it's like a
single giant
atomic nucleus 10 kilometers across it's
the end state of stars a bit more
massive than the sun
um and uh in a neutron star a neutron
star is held together by the strong
nuclear force
where in a sense every individual piece
of the neutron star is kind of held
on to the neighboring piece of neutron
star and then altogether you end up
getting this um
uh actually the the i guess the neutron
star is ultimately held together by
gravitational forces
but there's a local nuclear force that
holds together individual pieces of the
neutron star
um the uh in any case the
the the um uh so
what happens in
how to explain this the physics the the
official kind of graduate school physics
version of this is very straightforward
um but let me see if i can can explain
it um
basic point is that in order for the
neutron to decay
it has to
be able to the so when a neutron decays
the mass of the neutron is being
converted
to mass and energy there's there's
there's a conservation of energy which
can either be in the form of
mass or it can be in the form of sort of
more traditional energy
and kind of the the famous formula e
equals m c squared
tells you the conversion between sort of
ordinary kinds of energy
and energy associated with mass and what
ends up happening
is that in if the neutron is
kind of bound into a nucleus it's the
energy associated with that binding
uh means that the sort of total energy
of the neutron
is is made lower and the total energy is
sufficiently low
that it is below the place where you
would need below the energy that you
would need
to account for the mass of a proton plus
the mass of an electron
so the effective normally a neutron is
slightly more massive than a proton
and that's why a free neutron can decay
to a proton
electron it has the neutron mass is what
is it 939
million electron volts whereas a a um
the mass of the proton is around 938
million electron volts
and the mass of an electron is around
half a million electron volts
and so the mass of a proton plus the
mass of an electron
is less than the mass of a neutron which
is why a free neutron
can decay into a proton electron but
when it's bound into a nucleus the
binding energy in the nucleus
is larger than that difference or can be
larger than that difference and when
it's larger than that difference
the neutron simply doesn't have enough
energy
to be able to to produce to be able to
make the mass of a proton in the mass of
an electron so it can't decay
and so that's why neutrons in most
nuclei don't decay
but if the neutron is sort of a bit
loose in the nucleus it can decay and
that's what leads to beta decay
you can ask more questions about what is
the
underlying force underlying mechanism
for beta decay
i think i've talked about that um
previous time
in connection with the standard model of
particle physics
there's uh kind of these different kinds
of forces
um that we know exists between particles
there's electromagnetic forces that are
associated with electricity and
magnetism
and charged particles particles will
electric charge
um have those kinds of forces those
forces are the results of exchange of
photons
there are also the forces in nuclei
which i sort of explained
due to the exchange of pions but there's
that that there that well again it's a
little bit complicated but
but protons and neutrons themselves are
composite particles made of quarks
and those quarks are held together by
these things called gluons
which are kind of a little bit like
photons except that instead of being
dealing with electric charge they deal
with this thing called color charge
which is something that quarks have and
gluons have all sorts of weird
properties they
unlike photons which only interact with
charged particles
gluons have their own have charged
themselves
photons don't have charge themselves
they only interact with
other particles that have charge but
gluons have charged themselves and so
they interact with
have color charge themselves so they
interact with themselves
and that leads to all kinds of
complicated effects and it's sort of
the fact that they're kind of
interacting with themselves is what
forces them to kind of remain localized
and not be able to to um uh
to be seen as kind of free particles
that you could just uh pick up and have
a
glue on detector or something um and
uh the the roughly the whole mechanism
of pioneer exchange pions are quark
antiquark
particles but it's all kind of connected
to the way that quarks and gluons
interact so there's this
strong nuclear force that's more or less
that holds nuclei together
it's more or less associated with quarks
and particularly gluons
so there's this one additional piece
where it's like why does this exist
well we don't really know why it exists
yet
um but this is the so-called weak
nuclear force
which is responsible for beta decay and
the weak nuclear force
is associated with uh another kind of
charge
um that is uh um
uh is is well it's not usually given a
a specific name it's an su2 charge in
the in the theory of um
uh in the standard theory of particle
physics um
but it's a um uh
it's it's kind of another kind of charge
and
instead of photons being the thing that
uh is kind of uh is
is associated with that charge of things
called w particles
and uh photons are massless and uh if
you have a photon
it will just uh if you you know if you
shine a
a beam of light out into into a vacuum
that the beam of light will just keep
going forever
um the uh um
actually that's not probably the best
the best well
gosh this is kind of complicated you see
this is this is the problem that i
always um
uh in in terms of sort of official
graduate school physics
there's a fairly straight path through
explaining what i'm trying to explain
but it's not so easy if you if you would
if you
don't assume a whole bunch of of
knowledge about how physics works
but anyway this is called w particles
and
while photons are massless
and travel at the speed of light and so
on w particles
are not massless w particles have a mass
of about
65 times the mass of the proton so
they're kind of
comparable in mass to a kind of a
mid-range nucleus
a bit a bit heavier than iron nucleus of
iron the most common
uh version of the iron nucleus has a
mass of about 56
times the mass of the proton um but so
the w particle is a bit more massive
than that
just a single particle and that w
particle
it's the exchange of w particles that
leads to
uh weak nuclear forces or weak
interactions
um and it's those weak interactions that
uh lead to beta decay
so a bit of a bit of a long explanation
um but you know you can ask again
why do those weak interactions exist
uh we don't really know yet uh we know
that
in a kind of a theory of um
and kind of the fundamental theory of
physics as it's known in the standard
model of particle physics
these sort of official words are
it's an su-3 cross su-2 cross u1
gauge theory what does that mean uh
those those designations su-3 and su-2
those are symmetry groups okay what is
the symmetry group i can try and explain
some of that
so imagine you have an object
could pick up an object from somewhere
here imagine you have an object
and you can say uh let's
rotate that object around in space we
can ask the question if we make a
rotation if we
rotate it along
one axis we twist it around along one
axis then we twist it around along
another axis
then we twist it around on the first
axis again and then we twist around on
the other axis
how do these different transformations
combine is it the case that
for example if we twist around one axis
by 90 degrees then we twist it by
another 90 degrees
and then we can we do that let's say
it's twisting around
one axis by 90 degrees four times
it'll get back to where it started from
and uh we can keep doing these
transformations and we can kind of
uh catalogue what the combinations of
these transformations do
if you think about things like rubik's
cubes they have all kinds of
transformations and when you combine
those transformations together
eventually you can get the rubik's cube
to go back to where it started from
again
but there's this whole question of how
do you catalog
the possible transformations that you
can make on things like
cubes or like uh hexagons drawn in a
plane or any of these kinds of things
you can sort of catalogue those
transformations
and they're things like rotations
reflections
all kinds of other sorts of
transformations you can make
so you label each kind of transformation
and then you ask
what are the combinations of those
transformations how do they work
and the that idea
of sort of labeling transformations and
seeing how their combinations work
that idea is all connected with group
theory which is a
uh a kind of a a generalization of kind
of the ideas of algebra in mathematics
it was invented in the 1830s
uh originally by a chap called everest
galwa um
and uh the the idea is if you think
about
something that says rotate 90 degrees
you can call that like
r for example you do it again it's like
you've got r
times r do it again r times r times r do
it yet again
r to the power 4. and if r represents a
rotation through 90 degrees for example
you could say r to the power 4 is equal
to one
because if you do the rotation four
times you get back to what you started
from again and that's like multiplying
by one
so it's like that that gives you a a
relation in the group
you're saying you've got this
transformation this r
and you say this um uh this
that um uh that thing has
a particular sort of algebraic relation
like r to the fourth is equal to one
or you might have some two different
transformations you might have a
reflection here and a rotation there
and it might be the case that applying
the reflection first followed by the
rotation
is the same as applying the rotation
first followed by the reflection
that would be another kind of algebraic
relation between those
those kind of symbolic things that
represent those transformations
okay so group theory is this theory that
you get by making up all these sort of
algebraic relations between these
transformations
and then asking about different
properties of of the system that results
so for example in a finite group
which means a group where there are only
a limited number of these
uh different uh elementary operations
elementary
symbols and effect a finite group
there'll be results
like the fact that every element
eventually has an
order so if you apply the element enough
times you'll eventually get back what
you started from
and uh the um there'll be there are all
kinds of other things about subgroups
pieces of the group where different
elements in the group different
transformations
which can transform among themselves but
sort of stay away from other kinds of
things so for example
reflections can well rotations for
example
can be a separate subgroup that are
independent of reflections you can just
think about the rotations on their own
without ever getting involved with
reflections and so on
so there are a bunch of results about
group theory
and group theory is important in well
lots of different kinds of things it's
kind of a way of representing
symmetries of objects and uh you can say
this object has this kind of symmetry
it's it's um it's
it has the symmetry of the square for
example in the sense that you can rotate
it around after you rotate it four times
it comes back to what it started from
where it has the the
symmetry of the icosahedron so that's a
three-dimensional figure
and that means that uh all the
transformations correspond to ones which
are
things like rotations which take the
icosahedron
to to itself they're just rotations that
that um are just exchange faces of the
icosahedron so to speak
okay so that's sort of the idea of
finite groups
and there are many sort of statements
you can make about these finite groups
about orders of elements about the way
subgroups work about different kinds of
things
when you study crystals for example the
atoms and crystals
are arranged in definite ways that
correspond to different
finite symmetry groups so for example if
you have a crystal
where all the atoms are arranged uh
cubically like in in the case of
sodium chloride common salt um the the
atoms there
are all arranged just in a cubic lattice
so they're just there's like a big grid
of um uh that is just a um a big
sort of cubic grid of like like you just
have cubicle boxes
and you're stacking them up and it's
like the atoms live in these cubicle
boxes and you're stacking them all up
but you can have
other different kinds of crystal
structures for example another common
one
is called hexagonal close packing and
for example if you go to a grocery store
people still do that the if you look at
the way that spherical fruit is packed
so for example i don't know something
like oranges you'll often see there'll
be a big pile of oranges
and if you look at how those oranges are
arranged they'll be arranged in a way
where
there'll be sort of three oranges and
then one orange on top of those three
and so on
and that's a a form of packing that's a
sort of closest packing it's known
it's only proved very recently actually
um that the closest
packing of spheres that you could
possibly get is the one that people have
been using to stack fruit
for for centuries so to speak but that's
also the kind of
uh arrangement of atoms that exists in
lots of kinds of crystals
and that kind of arrangement of atoms
has a different symmetry group
that has a um uh let's see it's a
dodecahedral symmetry group no no no
that's not right
uh what is it um
i'm not completely sure uh takes a bit
of thought it's it corresponds to one of
the potential diet
maybe the octahedron that the the
icosahedron dodecahedron are
kind of weird with respect to the
symmetries like that because they don't
they don't
correspond to packings in the same way
possibly liquids may have
symmetry groups that are uh are on
average a bit like that
but anyway so so that corresponds to
another kind of symmetry that's
represented by one of these finite
groups
okay so that's finite groups
now there's another kind of group which
is
a continuous group or league lae
group named after a chap called sophis
lee who was norwegian
um the uh uh the idea of a lead group or
a continuous group
is it's dealing not with discrete
transformations like rotate by 90
degrees
and be back to the same after you did it
four times for example
but continuous transformations that can
be arbitrarily small
so in if you take a sphere for example
uh or even a circle let's just take a
circle if you move that circle just
infinitesimally
you can just by an infinitesimal angle
that's
an element of the continuous group of
the circle and you can you can just keep
moving the circle infinitesimally
and if you do it enough times eventually
the circle will come back to what it
started from again
but so what happens is there's a theory
of these kinds of continuous groups
and it's a theory it's kind of like if
you know about calculus
calculus is a theory of continuous
functions functions where
it's sort of as you as if a function f
of x you change
x just a tiny bit the value of the
function f of x will change just a tiny
bit as well
calculus is the theory of those kinds of
sort of
continuous changes the theory of
continuous groups
is a theory of kind of continuous
changes of of
continuous transformations associated
with symmetries and so on
and so for example the the group
associated with the circle
consists of so it can be sort of
generated by
this infinitesimal transformation that
you just turn the circle a little tiny
bit
for a sphere it's a little bit more
complicated if you imagine
what are the infinitesimal
transformations that you can make on a
sphere
which if you did them enough times would
let you turn the sphere from any
configuration to any other
there's no longer just one kind of
infinitesimal transformation
because you can kind of rotate the
sphere on its sort of polar axis you can
rotate the sphere
uh on its uh on sort of the the around
some point on the equator
you can make several different
transformations so there are
several so-called infinitesimal
generators
of the symmetry group of the sphere so
in the case of a circle
the infinitesimal generators are just
these things that just
move you turn the circle a little tiny
bit that's just one of them
on the sphere there are three
infinitesimal generators
that are necessary to be able to if you
combine them
and apply them enough times you can turn
the spear from any any
any any sphere to any other sphere so to
speak
just like when we're talking about a
square we're talking about
transformations which
take the square rotate it through 90
degrees which means you get the square
back again
um the same you know you've you've made
it the same square again but just
transformed
same thing for a sphere but now you're
applying sort of infinite number of
these infinitesimal transformations
okay so you can index these
infinitesimally you can think about the
sort of catalogue of these infinite
decimal transformations
just as you can think about the catalog
of finite transformations
for something like a square and the the
these infinitesimal transformations and
the official language of kind of
graduate school math uh are called uh
the lee algebra
um they're kind of the the the the sort
of the
the infinitesimal piece of the league
group which corresponds to the set of
all possible transformations of a sphere
so any case you can classify
for different kinds of objects like
spheres the group of the sphere
is called so3 the special orthogonal
group in three dimensions
and um that that represents it has as
its infinitesimal generators these three
different transformations
you can make on a sphere and you can
have different choices of those
generators and it's all a bit
complicated
but but basically that's the idea so for
a sphere
so3 for a circle it's called u1 it could
be called
so2 as well but it's it's really called
u1
is the um uh is the kind of the the lee
group that corresponds to
transformations on
on a of a circle and there are other
kinds of league groups but there's only
a finite number of possible league
groups
there are some families of league groups
like so uh it goes from
so uh you know s o
any number actually the ones that even
numbers are different from the ones in
odd numbers but that's not
let's ignore that but there are these
differently labeled kinds of groups
there's another family of groups the su
groups
su 2 su-3 su-4 etc
these are groups mathematically those
are groups that can be represented using
unitary matrices
but that's irrelevant for these purposes
they're just
groups of symmetries of things that
aren't quite geometrical objects like
spheres
you can think of them if you think about
complex numbers they they're a version
of
of kind of symmetries of of things you
can make with complex numbers
but um uh you can just think of them as
a symmetry transfer abstract symmetry
transformations
okay why am i telling you all this stuff
well when we have sort of the
physical objects in space there are
physical transformations you can make
like the things i was describing
rotation group for a sphere
but one of the things that happens in
physics
is there is the notion of kind of an
internal symmetry group
not something that is associated with
space not something that's associated
with
ordinary transformations of moving
things in space but something which is
somehow associated with an internal
space
that exists in in particles and so on
now actually in our model of physics
there is a deep entangling of
physical space of the kind that you can
move around in
and this kind of internal space and it's
it's a quite
elaborate kind of uh way in which
the kind of the stuff that makes up
physical space
also makes up this kind of internal
space
but roughly what's happening is that
particles
there's this sort of internal space
associated with particles
and you can think of it as you know the
particle is kind of it's not
quite it's not really it's not like
physically rotating around the particle
it's something that is an internal
feature of the particle
that is transforming in the kind of way
that one would transform
for example turning a spear around okay
so that's a long story
but it turns out that
those internal symmetries um
are we we in in physics
the internal symmetries associated
particles we know
are there's an su3 symmetry which is
associated with
color charge as an su2 and a u1 symmetry
those are associated roughly with the
weak charge
and with electromagnetic charge and okay
there's one more wrinkle here
which is this idea of so-called local
gauge theories
oh boy let's see if i can explain this
so one thing you can ask is
you say i have a spear i rotate it
around
i i want it to be the case that uh sort
of nothing really changes
if i just rotate things around so let me
give you an example
of of the universe for example uh let's
say that we
have set ourselves up and we say that
we're setting up coordinates in the
universe and we say
uh you know the x direction in the
universe goes from here to the andromeda
galaxy
the y coordinate is going in the
direction of some other some other
galaxy or something we've set up those
coordinates
and we say how does the universe work
with respect to those coordinates then
we say
okay now i'm going to uh i'm going to
ask is the universe rotationally
symmetric
does it matter whether one is does it
matter the laws of physics does it
matter to the laws of mechanics
whether this rocket is going uh towards
the moon or towards mars does it doesn't
make any difference
what the sort of actual uh orientation
in space is
for something and the answer is of
course if there are things in space like
planets and so on
there can be gravity from those and that
makes a difference but if you're just
sort of an empty space
we believe that the universe is such
that it is isotropic in the sense that
it doesn't matter
nothing depends on which absolute
direction you're going in in space
and so we can think about that as it is
rotationally invariant if we take
the direction our rocket is going and we
rotate things around
we'll always get the same kind of
physics for what's happening
okay so that's kind of at the level of
large-scale physical space
okay when it comes to these internal
symmetries there is a a somewhat
different thing instead of saying
we're just going to take the whole
universe and rotate it around we're
going to say
we can actually pick quite locally
whether we consider sort of the x
direction to be this direction and the y
direction to be that direction
or whether we we can consider we can we
can treat it to be the case
that that completely locally we can pick
which which direction is x which
direction is y and so on
with respect to this internal symmetry
and
the claim that's being made is that
physics is such that you can
independently locally pick those
coordinate systems
now if you just were just to say i'm
just going to pick these local
coordinate systems
at at random so to speak and then i'm
going to pick them again
that won't work what has to happen is if
you if you pick them randomly at first
and then you say oh this one i want to
change this one
somehow in order to make things
consistent the information that you
changed this one
has to be somehow propagated to other
ones
and in the language of fancy mathematics
one talks about
the symmetry group being associated with
talks about the thing called the fiber
bundle
and essentially what happens there is
that there's a sort of a
a um you think about at every point in
space
there's like a fiber like a a um you
know like a tuft in a carpet or
something
uh if that was a two-dimensional space
it would be like the the tufts and the
carpet and every one of those tufts is a
fiber
and in the sort of in that fiber
one's thinking about the operation of
the symmetry group it's a little bit
hard to visualize that
but that's sort of the mathematical idea
is there's this
this bundle of fibers in every fiber
there's kind of a
a a copy of the symmetry group and every
fiber you could sort of pick the
coordinate system
uh in that symmetry for the for that
symmetry group separately
and then there's this notion of what's
called a connection on the fiber bundle
which is kind of a mathematical concept
at first
that basically says if you move from one
fiber to another
how how does the does the coordinate
system change from one fiber to another
you say well okay that just sounds like
a bunch of fancy mathematics
what does that have to do with anything
real it turns out the connections and
fiber bundles
uh correspond precisely to the idea of
things like photons
in electromagnetism because what's
happening is electromagnetism is what's
called local gauge theory
it's a u1 local gauge theory so in all
of its sort of fibers
there's a copy of this u1 symmetry group
which is kind of
the circle the symmetry group of the
circle and what's happening is that sort
of the orientation of those
internal circles can be arbitrary
is is different in different places in
space
but sort of knowing about changes in
that orientation
that the knowledge of that change is
kind of uh
carried by these photons that can go
from one part of space to another
so that was a that's kind of a very
rough explanation of the idea of local
gauge theories
um which is the kind of the
the uh the foundation of the sort of
standard model of particle physics
and these particles like the photon the
photon is said to be the gauge boson
associated with the local gauge group
for electromagnetism
the local gauge group for
electromagnetism is u1 by the way if
you know more about how electromagnetism
works one of the things you may know
is that you talk about you have a
let's say a circuit and you say
uh there's a certain voltage between
this part of the circuit and this other
part of the circuit there's a certain
voltage
across this resistor or something in the
circuit but
the voltage the the the
voltage is a difference between electric
potential
and electric potential is this kind of
abstract thing
that uh is that sort of defines the flow
of electrons when the electrons will
flow
from a uh uh well they're negatively
charged so it's all a bit messed up but
but roughly
they'll flow from higher electric
potential to lower electric potential
um and uh but the the zero of electric
potential is not defined
you can you can say this is my zero volt
place in my circuit it's here and then
this other thing is plus 10 volts
relative to the zero
or you can pick the zero put the zero in
a different place you could
you could say actually my whole circuit
is you know it starts off my
my ground is minus 20 volts and
everything's relative to that so it only
matters
only the relative voltage matters
because that's what eventually is going
to determine sort of the pushing of
electrons through wires and things like
this
and so that arbitrariness
of the zero voltage turns out to be
the thing that is the local gauge and
the gauging variants associated with
electromagnetism
uh it what starts as being just this
linear scale
um ends up being actually a rotation
because of
the way that one sets it up in terms of
of complex numbers and things like this
but that's that's kind of
why there's that that's a kind of a sign
of its local gauge and variance for
electromagnetism
but gauging variance for
electromagnetism leads the existence of
photons
photons are sort of what carry the
information associated with that
so for the weak uh weak
symmetry weak charges um the
the gauge bosons associated with weak
charges of w particles
and also z particles the gauge bosons
associated with color charges are the
gluons
um and so there's kind of a very uniform
way in which these theories work
it's a little bit weird and it took a
long time for people to understand this
photons are massless w particles as i
say have a mass 65 times the mass of the
proton
so how come one gauge boson is massless
another gage bone has a
gauge boson has a great big mass the the
thing that accounts for that is this
thing called the higgs mechanism
um which is a kind of hokey piece of
particle physics
which maybe will change eventually um
but basically what happens is really the
w boson
sort of really is a massless particle
just like the photon
but throughout the universe there's this
kind of um
uh there's this higgs field that sort of
permeates the whole universe
and as w bosons go through this higgs
field
they are effectively they keep on
getting stopped and started stops and
started they're interacting with the sex
field
and that interaction causes them to
behave as if they have a mass
um and that's that the higgs field is
actually the way that that all particles
are thought to get masses um but it's a
it's
and there are actually uh sort of there
are higgs particles
which are kind of excitations in this
higgs field and the higgs particles
themselves
get mass from interacting with this
background higgs field
the higgs particle has a mass of about
125 uh times the mass of a proton
it was only fairly recently discovered a
few years ago
in in particle collisions and so on
so okay that was a very long explanation
i'm sorry that was a um
uh um um
let's see uh there's a sort of follow-on
question
from this about um uh
from lurch confused about the mass of
quarks inside protons and neutrons
ah yes yes yes okay
um all right in my in my compressed
version of of uh graduate school
mathematical physics let me try and
explain that
so inside a proton
roughly protons are made of three quarks
two up quarks and a down quark
you can say what's the mass of a proton
okay i
i can i can figure out the mass of a
proton it's 938 point something million
electron volts
that's a that's the measure of mass it's
about um uh 10 to the minus 26 kilograms
if i remember correctly
um so it's a very uh uh on on a on a
so the the um
uh there's a definite mass for a proton
so you say well what's the mass of an up
quark
they say i'd have to say well i don't
really know say how can you not know
what the mass of an up quark is
after all every proton in the universe
has has a couple of up quarks and down
quark in it
well the reason is that quarks never
exist outside of things like protons or
neutrons so far as we know and probably
the case
that proton quarks are permanently
confined
inside protons and neutrons they
what happens if you try and if you kick
a proton really hard
let's say you fire an electron into a
proton and it it kind of
kicks the things that are inside the
proton well what happens is
the proton will kind of deform and it'll
you know kind of a piece of it will be
sort of it will be to push out to one
side
but it turns out that the that the
forces associated with gluons
are such that the the further you pull
it out
the stronger the force will be so for
example if you have a spring
you pull a spring a spring that the more
you pull the spring out
the stronger the spring will try and
pull you back
if you have something which has a
gravitational force
or an electromagnetic force the further
apart
those objects become the smaller the
force will be
it goes down like the inverse the the
one over the square of the distance in
that case
but if you have the force associated
with
with color charge the force associated
with gluons
that force is one that actually
increases as you pull the things further
and further apart
it increases probably roughly linearly
if you pull the thing apart
it'll be it'll just get uh this force
will get stronger and stronger
so that's kind of the reason why there
aren't any free quarks because if you
try and pull the quark out
it will it will make pull it a certain
distance actually what will happen is
if you pull it far enough out there will
be so much energy associated with the
pulling back of that cork
there will be enough energy to create
cork antiquark
pairs from the vacuum so in other words
there will be so much energy there that
it is
uh that there'll be enough energy
available
that they can make masses of quarks that
they can that energy
can be used to make a whole quark and to
to provide
the mass necessary to make a chord so
you can ask
why is it the case that
um uh that um
there's that these uh gluons and things
um produce this force law that's so
different from the force law
associated with other gauge bosons like
the photon the reason is because gluons
interact with themselves photons do not
photons if you take two beams of light
and you shine them through each other
they'll just go straight through
there's a tiny effect called light by
light scattering
where photons will actually interact
with each other but it's a tiny tiny
tiny effect
um it has to do with producing virtual
electron positron pairs
and all kinds of fancy quantum field
theory things but it's very small effect
for gluons if you could make beams of
gluons which you can't because they're
permanently confined
inside things like protons but if you
could make a beam of gluons
you took these two beams of gluons and
you had them collide
they would they would just interact they
would dramatically interact with each
other
they wouldn't just go straight through
each other okay so what does that mean
well it means
if you imagine gluons that you have two
quarks
here and here and you have the forces
between these quarks are associated with
essentially gluons
being produced bouncing back and forth
between these two quarks
the question is as these gluons normally
if you have something like an electric
charge it's effectively producing what
are called virtual photons
all streaming out in all directions and
the photons don't interact with each
other so a photon that's streaming out
along you know
from the north pole doesn't interact
with the one that's streaming out from
the south pole and so on
and so as you get further away from the
thing where these photons are all
streaming out
at any given any given place the the um
the density of those photons will be
smaller and smaller
because they're all they're streaming
out in all directions and so you can see
that that the number that hit any
particular
region will get less and less as you get
further and further away
however in the case of gluons the gluons
interact with each other
so instead of it being the case that the
gluons can also stream out in all
directions independently
the gluons all glum gum themselves
together
and effectively what happens is the
gluons make this kind of
a string of gluons between particles
because the gluons instead of wanting to
go out all
separately in all different directions
the gluons want to all be together
they want to all make this this sort of
single lump
of stuff it isn't really a lump it's
it's all much more virtualized than that
but
but that's kind of the idea they all
kind of uh clump together
and so that means there's this kind of
string of gluons between particles
and that means as you pull the particles
further apart instead of
it just being the case that fewer and
fewer gluons can hit the other particle
because they're just because they're
they're further away and they're so
stringing out in all directions
the same number of gluons get to the
other particle and so the force doesn't
go down
so that's roughly the reason for the
fact that the force associated with
gluons goes
up with distance rather than going down
the distance and
but that's the reason that gluons are
sort of permanently confined
uh that that quarks and gluons are
permanently confined inside particles
and
when they're permanently confined that
the
the other thing that happens is the that
sort of
confinement has that just like nuclei
have a certain binding energy associated
with the fact that the neutrons and
protons are all being sort of pulled
together
the same is true inside inside protons
there's a certain binding energy
and actually the the majority of the
mass of a proton
is just binding energy so in a neutron
in a nucleus
most of the energy of a nucleus is
uh most of the mass of a nucleus is
accounted for by
by just adding up the masses of the
protons and neutrons inside it
there's a small mass defect typically
associated with the binding energy
that's that holds the nucleus together
but that mass defect
is usually maybe a thousandth of the
mass of the nucleus something like that
mass defect
is very important and changes in that
mass defect are what allow you to have
nuclear reactors
and what lead to radioactive decay and
all kinds of things like this
but it's a small effect relative to the
mass of a nucleus in the case of a
proton
the vast majority of the mass of a
proton is associated with gluon binding
energy um
that holds those um uh um
uh that holds those um uh
those some uh those particles together
um the um the thing that um
uh so when you have something like a
proton
the up and down quarks have very low
mass
and so that binding energy is important
when you have there are six kinds of
quarks that we know about
probably that's all that there are the
up cork the down quark those are in
protons
the strange quark the charm quark the uh
bottom cork and the top cork
top cork was only discovered fairly
recently has a mass of 173 times the
mass of a proton
roughly um and that um
if you have a particle made from
uh top quarks and bottom quarks
charm corks things like that in that
case the binding energy
is actually quite small compared to the
mass of the quarks
the binding energy is usually roughly
well it's on the order of maybe
a temp the mass of a proton something
like that it's kind of the binding
energy
in your average well it's a little bit
complicated but in your average proton
the binding energy is about the mass of
the proton
and the pion which is about one-tenth
the mass of a proton there's binding
energy there
which is slightly smaller for various
reasons but basically
in in these light particles like protons
light relative to other things
like protons uh most of the most of
their mass is contributed by binding
energy
when you get um uh these things made
with heavy corks
there's a an amount of binding energy
that's comparable to the mass of a
proton
but that's small compared to the masses
of these quarks
so that was a um uh
boy that was a long description of um
lots of particle physics uh
let's see
well there's all kinds of questions here
let me just address a couple more
so the question here do you think you'll
be able to wirelessly charge your house
in your lifetime
um depends on how much you want to be
cooked
i mean when you have these wireless
chargers
how do they work they are inductive
charges
so one feature of
uh electromagnetism is that if you have
uh an electric current going around in a
in a circle
and a wire then it will tend to induce
an electric current in another wire and
that's
that's how these inductive charges work
that's the
process i mean a little bit more
complicated than that and involves
magnetism
and but that's roughly the idea
and what's happening is that there is a
uh it's an electromagnetic
um it's it's
it's not an electromagnetic wave like
light it's another way in which
electromagnetism
in which one piece of electric activity
can affect another piece of electric
activity it's the same
underlying equations the same underlying
theory
but it just is applied in a slightly
different way than
um it is in the case of producing um
something like a light wave or
something of that kind but um a large
magnetic induction
is the way these charges work is by
using that to make the conduction
but i think it's the case that if you
want to
uh and there's sort of that produces
an electromagnetic effect
that can um go
through um that can go through space
like like a large magnetic wave like a
photon
like a like a light or something but it
just has a different characteristic and
i'm
i'm i think i backed myself into i can
explain how that works but it requires
a bit of fancy um discussion i think
about the details of how electromagnet
electromagnetism
is set up but suffice it to say that
process of sort of transmitting
electromagnetic
energy from one thing to another
that that energy exists between those
things
um it's it's kind of like the same kind
of energy that exists inside a microwave
oven or something
it's sort of uh it's
an electromagnetic field
that exists in sort of an empty space so
to speak
well the problem is that electromagnetic
field
has an effect on charged particles like
electrons
that exist in the things that it
encounters
and that's why it has the effect of of
uh
being able to charge your phone or
whatever it's
it's uh it's sort of moving around the
electrons
um and and uh just like plugging the um
uh the phone into the wall would be
pushing electrons around
that eventually will charge the battery
of the phone so if you have that kind of
electromagnetic field
and you're trying to charge things that
way the problem is
that if you have something that's in
that electromagnetic field that isn't
the thing you're trying to charge
like if you walk through that
electromagnetic field
then you will be charged so to speak
or more to the point you'll be uh
treated kind of like
food in a microwave oven um you'll
you'll have
kind of electromagnetic uh you'll you'll
have the same
kind of electromagnetic processes that
cause
the molecules and and the food in the
microwave oven to spin around
and heat up and so on those things will
happen to you and i don't know whether
there's a way
to avoid that happening i i would
suspect
um uh you know there's sort of the
question of whether there's
a way to have uh inductive charging
so that you don't have something that
can also cook
other things and i don't know the answer
to that
people believe a a magnetic field
a a pure magnetic field that doesn't
um the the magnetic field like the one
you get from a bar magnet for example
um people might think that
that has no real effect on
uh on us humans you know you have a bar
magnet
you put it next to your hand doesn't
seem to do anything to your hand
we don't seem to have any magnetic uh
nothing about
us seems to be seems to care about about
magnetism about
ordinary static magnetism not
electromagnetic fields which involve
changes of electrical and magnetic
uh potentials and things but just static
magnetic fields
um we don't seem to care about those
well
more or less people have long believed
that for example
pigeons are sensitive to the magnetic
field of the earth
that somehow there is a uh inside
one of the proteins in the brain of a
project pigeon there is
some some uh uh
some something that in which the
the um the way that the spins of
electrons
are aligned um is affected by the
earth's magnetic field
and that that the way the protein
operates depends on these electron spins
which in turn are affected by the
earth's magnetic field and so
people have believed that sort of homing
pigeons partly home
by virtue of knowing the direction of
magnetic field and so
a a recent but fairly credible theory
is that um uh there are actually many
proteins that are sensitive to magnetic
fields and for example it could very
well be
that um uh the proteins that are
associated with our circadian rhythm
our kind of the way that our bodies
change when
we get used to sort of a roughly 24-hour
cycle of
light and dark sleep and wakefulness and
so on
there are proteins that that are
associated with that
kind of clock that rhythm and there's
some evidence that those proteins
actually are affected by magnetic fields
um so the idea that there's nothing in
us
that cares about magnetic fields may not
in fact be true
um whether we should worry about that
and whether we should be um
uh thinking about gosh if we if we live
in this big magnetic field is it going
to change us in weird ways
i don't know it certainly always used to
be said by by physicists i knew
who worked around very large magnetic
fields that you could have you know
if you were in a high magnetic field you
get this strange taste in your mouth
and it's not completely implausible why
that might happen
because there are features of kind of
the way that the electrochemistry of
taste works
that might depend on some magnetic kinds
of processes
and of course then the question is if
you get you know an mri done
which involves a large magnetic field um
you know does that happen and one
doesn't usually hear about that
so that's probably a sign that there
isn't such an effect there
but i'm not sure um but so i think the
answer is
um it's uh for uh
for things necessary to do charging i
don't think that i i think that's tough
to make it work
um the uh
um there's a comment here from
there's a comment from anders didn't
tesla invent wireless electricity
i i i don't know exactly what
what tesla invented along those lines i
i think it was this kind of inductive
charging idea but i'm not sure
um and uh william is commenting does
solo count as wireless charging
i don't know in some sense but that's a
little weird i mean in solar power what
you're doing is you're taking
light and using photovoltaic
materials which just mean turning light
to electricity
materials to um to generate electricity
and what's basically happening
is a photon from light from the light
um hits essentially an electron
in the material and kind of makes it
be uh gives it
kind of gives it energy
that essentially generates an electric
voltage
that can is the thing that is
is uh what can be used to charge a
battery or or generate power or whatever
else
so essentially the instead of you having
a voltage
that is uh which you get
sort of from the outside and pulling
electrons through that way
essentially what's happening is that
photons are
giving electrons the kick that they need
to generate a voltage
and that's sort of the rough way that
that
photovoltaic cells work
and they work well in more detail they
work using semiconductors
the same kind of thing that's used to
make microprocessors and so on
but set up in a different way
well i think we should probably wrap up
soon i'm sorry i've spent longer than i
i
expected on um
on that term physics question
um
yeah somebody is commenting that um
tesla's
wireless power experiment the warden
cliff tower
now i've that that thing is in new
jersey and
uh i think it's in new jersey at least
um
pretty sure i've seen that thing it's
it's in some um
i think there's a there's a big effort
to make a museum around it and i don't
know whether that's been successful yet
um but i think it's in new jersey and i
think i've seen the thing and it's sort
of just in some random parking lot and
it's kind of
just kind of nearby um thomas edison's
um sort of much fancier workshop not
sure
um
okay maybe one more question maybe a
simple one let's see if there are any
simple ones here
oh boy
um
hmm
well
okay do two here there's one from anna
can human electromagnetic fields
interfere with electricity
so us humans
have definite electrical effects um
of different kinds so for example
the way that um uh
well we are in a first approximation
sort of bags of water
and um the uh you know our cells contain
lots of water
that's the most common substance in us
and
water has certain electrical properties
and so
when we have um um
well here's a very elementary case so
when you hold a cell phone
you are uh actually i'm not sure how
this works these days
if you hold the metal part of a cell
phone you are definitely becoming part
of the antenna for the cell phone if you
have a case on your cell phone i'm less
clear how that works actually
but if you if you hold the sort of the
if you if you sort of um if let's say
old-fashioned thing if you have sort of
one of those antennas that's just kind
of a
a straight kind of a you know
telescoping antenna or something made of
metal
and you grab on to that antenna you in a
sense become part of that
antenna and so the the electromagnetic
waves that that antenna is picking up
it will potentially pick up more of
those electromagnetic waves
um by virtue of you uh you know you you
act as some
some piece of the sort of antenna that's
connected to that now the way that works
with cell phones is kind of complicated
because
one of the issues is when you pick up a
cell phone the cell phone usually
will try and decrease its power
the amount of power it's sending um
because
it's trying to not cook your hand so to
speak and so
there's all kinds of different uh things
if you look at the
for example the the filings that are
made with the fcc the federal
communications commission
um by companies like apple they show all
the tests that get done
on things like cell phones to show you
know how much electromagnetic radiation
are you getting in your hand and so on
and i think there are there are these
different kinds of grips
that you can make to a cell phone i
think there's one that gets called the
maybe it's called the vulcan death grip
or something i'm not sure but but it's
one where you're really holding on very
very tight
and the the phone will react to that and
change the amount of
energy that it's putting out into it
into its antenna
um and there are it has a very elaborate
kind of system of trying to have the
phone put up as much energy
as as you can um i think maybe uh
not sure the phone these days sort of
uses you as part of its antenna or not
um and um uh and then trying to sort of
not
cook you so to speak but um
but in general you know
humans have a big effect on
electromagnetic waves that are sort of
propagating around like if you have
wi-fi wi-fi is electromagnetic waves
that are propagating around
and you can if you measure in detail
the the amount of the wi-fi signal that
collected at different places
you can detect the fact that people are
walking around in a room
by just seeing that the wi-fi signal
will be attenuated by somebody walking
in front of something
etcetera etcetera etcetera so you can
have an effect that way
um the uh when it comes to
our um uh
our nerves for example work electrically
we're generating electrical impulses
that's what
our nerves use to drive our muscles if
you're asking
whether it's possible for that kind of
electricity
to have an effect outside i don't think
so for humans
if you're an electric eel it's a
different story an electric eel
kind of produces its electricity in the
same kind of way it's kind of like a
battery same way that electricity is
produced
in nerve cells and so on but the
electric eel is kind of a
you know does it as a sort of oversized
nerve cell and the electric eel
um produces enough uh uh
enough charge it gets itself charged up
enough that it can actually
have an effect and you know attack its
prey
using by by um giving an electric shock
and so on
i don't think humans can do that um i
don't think
uh we have any mechanism for um
generating enough
um electric uh charge to be able to do
anything like that although
you know one could imagine some strange
story where somebody
has managed to uh to train themselves to
to operate their nerves and muscles in
just such a way
as to be like a kind of simulation
electric eel but i haven't had
heard of such a thing um so that's uh uh
that's the story there all right last
last question for today
um from cast uh
what is something you've recently
changed your perspective or opinion
about
maybe this is too long am
uh gosh
that could be too long question i'm i
mean one example of that
this is going to get me into a way long
answer which i can't really give right
now
but um the question of uh consciousness
and what consciousness
is is something that i have always
avoided because i've always thought
there isn't anything very scientific to
say about it
and i realized a little while ago that
actually
with our new theory of physics and so on
there is a way to think about
kind of what consciousness is and the
way in which
consciousness kind of a sort of defining
feature of consciousness
is something that one might have thought
was sort of a triviality
and not the main point but it's actually
a defining feature and it's the notion
that there is a definite kind of
sequence of experience that uh
consciousness corresponds to in other
words
there's a w we have a definite sort of
thread of experience that's an essence
of sort of our conscious experiences
there's a definite thread
through time of experience it's not like
all these different things are happening
all these different places
and all the different neurons in our
brains are firing and doing different
kinds of things
rather sort of an essential feature of
consciousness
is at least this perception that there's
a definite kind of sequentialized thread
of experience
that kind of runs through what we what
we
experience and remember and so on and
what i kind of realized
is that that sort of notion of a
sequentialized thread of experience
is something which deeply affects the
way that we view the world
and if it wasn't for that we would view
things like space and time
and lots of other kinds of things in
very different ways the fact that we
have this kind of sequentialized view
of a definite thread of experience is
ultimately what drives
the way that we perceive the way that
the physical world works
and so that's something i've very much
changed my mind on if you'd asked me
um six months ago what i thought about
consciousness i would have said
i don't have anything to say about it i
now think there's something very
definite to say about it
and it all has to do with this kind of
sequentialized thread of experience
which is what leads us to the physics
that we have
if if we didn't have that sort of
sequentialized thread of experience
we would have a very different view of
how the universe works
and what physics is like and so that's
led me to
all kinds of interesting uh thoughts
about whether consciousness is sort of
what what you would conclude about the
universe
if you were set up differently and uh
kind of what how you would parse the
different pieces of space
and so on in the universe if it wasn't
for the fact that you have this sort of
sequentialized thread of consciousness
also makes me realize that things like
human language which is a very
sequential thing you know it's
one word comes after another comes after
another we don't have sort of a
an array of different things going on um
we we tend to think about things in sort
of a sequential fashion like that
we tend to express them in language in a
sequential fashion
that seems to me to be i'm realizing
not something which is just oh it
happens that way and we could train
ourselves to do something different
but that's a fundamental feature of the
way that we exist
and the way that we experience the world
and that has consequences
if you're trying to program a computer
and you want the computer to be doing
all sorts of different things
all roughly at the same time in parallel
that's the thing that has been very hard
for people to understand how to do
and i think we're kind of seeing why
because in some sense it's something
that is
incompatible with our core features of
consciousness so to speak
and so that's that's a that's sort of
the reason for that difficulty
and it kind of gives one some idea of
how one might try to resolve that
difficulty
or maybe what maybe it's really hard
because us humans are just stuck
in this kind of thread of experience uh
way of thinking about things
you know we can imagine the ais and we
can imagine
sort of they might have a different way
of doing
this process of thinking about things
the problem is
if they don't have something which is
sort of sequentialized
like our threat of experience they will
just look to us
as if they're doing kind of random
computational things just like
any old system in nature they won't seem
to have the same
kinds of thinking like processes that we
have so
this is something that i've i've rather
changed my mind on and to
to make a bit of a cliffhanger i think
one of the things that um
that view of of of things
has led me to is back to a really old
question
which is one of these questions which
it's like how could you possibly answer
this question
which is why does the universe exist and
but a different way why is there
something rather than nothing
why does anything exist and uh
the surprise to me in the last week or
two
is that i actually think i've i've i've
got now a credible answer to that
question
which depends deeply on kind of a stack
of ideas
that come out of sort of studying the
computational universe
uh physics project and so on but it's
kind of kind of interesting and i i've
been sort of surprised
as i've been looking around at you know
what do other people say about why does
the universe exist
and why is there something rather than
nothing and i have to say it's pretty
thin
you know there's a lot of kind of word
play about well if there's nothing then
you can't talk about it so therefore
there has to be something and so on but
that's really just word play
um and in terms of of having any kind of
reasoned account of that it is
surprisingly thin
uh from from what i have found and it's
been a
been really a surprise to me that i
think there is a sort of scientific
kind of answer to that question and uh
hopefully coming in the next few weeks
we'll see and uh but it's it's one of
those things where
where it's it's a pretty elaborate sort
of tower of logic
although in the end the argument is
fairly simple um
and if it wasn't fairly simple i really
wouldn't believe in it at all
but um uh that's something that as i
said i've i've
uh i would have said if you'd asked me
well i've been thought of thinking about
this a bit for the last year because
once one has what one thinks is a
fundamental theory of physics
a fundamental theory of the universe the
obvious question is
you know why this universe and not
another um
it's some um
uh you know why um uh and then
uh why is there any universe at all and
you know i i almost feel a bit silly and
and rj has commented that i should
i should give the the sum up here is
quotes i've answered why there's
something rather than nothing tune in
next week
um and i suppose i could say that but uh
um the um
um i always feel a bit silly
even having a discussion of that
question because it seems like
one of these questions that's just
fraught with with sort of
uh philosophical wordplay and so on but
as i say to my surprise you asked me the
question
um uh you know what's something i
recently changed my perspective or
opinion about
um that's something i've changed my
opinion about
and how that's going to work out we will
have to see maybe i'll change my opinion
again
and realize that um what i figured out
so far isn't right for some reason but
it looks pretty solid to me
okay i should wrap up here for now and
um
uh thanks for joining us and uh
see you another